nowadays index fund investing is one of
the most popular and reliable ways to
grow your wealth over the long term and
given the high diversification the low
volatility and extreme ease of index
funds it's no wonder they're so popular
but index funds aren't a classic
investment tool like you might think
just 30 years ago index funds were
largely avoided and 50 years ago index
fund investing wasn't even a thing
it wasn't until 1972 that the world's
first index fund was created vanguard
entered the scene a few years later in
1975 and since then they've grown to be
the king of index funds the largest
index fund today is actually the spdr
spy etf but this is more of an anomaly
if you look right below spy you'll see
that 5 out of the top 10 funds are from
vanguard and that 31 out of the top 100
funds are also from vanguard so here's
how vanguard became the second largest
investment firm in the world by just
embracing average
it all started with a man named john c
bogal who was born on may 8th 1929 right
before the great depression jon's family
unfortunately got annihilated by the
great depression his parents lost all of
their savings and they were forced to
sell their house john's father basically
gave up on life and became an alcoholic
which resulted in jon's parents
divorcing so from a very young age jon
was on his own and his clearest path to
success was education
john and his twin brother david both
worked extremely hard at school to try
to get ahead and this would end up
paying off
john stella academic record earned him a
spot at an elite boarding school named
blair academy on a fulbright works
scholarship
today blair academy charges 66 500 per
year and they only have a total of 462
students
so i think it's safe to assume that they
don't give out these spots very easily
anyway jon continued to excel at blair
and he would eventually get accepted
into princeton at princeton john majored
in economics and investments and it
didn't take him long to delve into the
world of mutual funds
during his junior and senior years in
college john wrote a graduating thesis
paper called the economic role of the
investment company this paper would
actually get john his first job
the story goes that walter l morgan the
founder of the wellington fund read
john's 130 page paper and that he hired
john right after
john quickly became a star at the fund
and by 1955 john was promoted to being
an assistant manager of the fund
john also pushed for the creation of a
new fund that was less concentrated than
wellington's other funds jon would get
his way and this new fund turned out to
be a great success soon enough watch a
morgan would retire from the company in
1970 and he would choose jon to be a
successor
things were going phenomenally for jon
he had become the leader of a
well-respected fund at a rather young
age of 41 years old
but unfortunately john would make a
fateful decision that would get mastered
from the company
in the 1970s john approved a merger that
turned out to be a disaster and jon
would be fired soon after
though this was likely a terrible
experience what's surprising is that jon
never complained about it or tried to
make excuses
in fact he describes the mistake as
quote shameful and inexcusable and a
reflection of immaturity and confidence
beyond what the facts justified
it's crazy how down to earth and humble
jon was despite all of his success john
decided to start his own investment firm
named vanguard in 1974 and that brings
us to the creation of the index fund
john is often credited with inventing
the world's first index fund but this is
actually not the case
their first idea for an index fund dates
back to university of chicago students
edward renshaw and paul feldstein
suggested the idea of creating an
unmanaged investment company way back in
1960 but the idea barely got any support
and it didn't go anywhere a decade later
though a company named qualitex funding
would make their vision a reality by
creating a fund that tracked the dow
jones industrial average on july 31 1972
so john was not the first to create an
index fund but he's still no doubt the
father of index fund investing given
that he was the one to popularize it
jon launched vanguard's first index fund
called the first index investment trust
on december 31st 1975. the success of
vanguard didn't just happen overnight
though because there was a massive
problem in the 1970s there was very
little respect for index fund investing
within wall street fund managers thought
that the idea of index funds was
whimsical and utterly pointless it
wasn't just fund managers saying this
either most investors held a similar
belief due to two key reasons
first of all investors felt that they
could just do it themselves if they
wanted to all an index fund is doing is
splitting the money you invest across
dozens or hundreds of companies
depending on what the fund is tracking
investors can easily just do that
themselves in the 1970s they could call
up their brokerage and tell them to
split their money across nasdaq stocks
or s p 500 stocks the investor wouldn't
even have to go through the tediousness
of buying 500 different stocks that was
the brokerage's problem the second
argument against index funds was that it
was quote unquote un-american and
counter-intuitive people invest with
fund managers to beat the market not to
match the market
this is why the chairman of fidelity
edward johnson said that he couldn't
believe that the great massive investors
would be satisfied with receiving just
average returns
and these fund managers were right about
vanguard at least at the start the
launch of the first index investment
trust was a massive disappointment john
was hoping to raise 150 million during
the ipo but they only ended up raising a
measly 11 million dollars
now you might be thinking that 11
million dollars isn't that bad
but the thing to keep in mind is that
vanguard is just a manager of assets
which means that they're only paid a
very small percentage of what they
manage
even if they're charged one percent
which is super high for a passive fund
they would only make 110 000 per year
and that money isn't just for john that
money needs to support the operations of
the entire company
fortunately vanguard was just a group of
three people including jon and two
analysts so the overhead costs weren't
that large nonetheless the ipo was
extremely disappointing the banks that
helped john complete the ipo advised
that he should shut down the fund given
the poor reception but jon refused
john strongly believed that index fund
investing would become popular for two
of his own reasons
his first argument was that the fees of
an index fund just had to be low enough
for it to be worth investors time
the s p 500 adds companies and kicks out
companies on a quarterly basis so if
you're trying to track the s p 500 on
your own you would have to rebound your
portfolio every quarter also every time
you wanted to add money in or take money
out of your portfolio you'd have to buy
or sell the stocks of 500 different
companies
and whether it's investor doing it
themselves or the broker doing it on the
behalf of the investor someone has to
spend the time and money to accurately
track the desired index
if you were able to offer this service
for a silly low price investors and
brokers may very well be interested
since the start of vanguard one of the
key characteristics has been their
stupid low fees
the annual fee of their s p 500 fund
booo for instance is only 0.03 percent
per year
this means that for every 10 000 to
invest vanguard only charges three
dollars per year
i think you can see why this is quite
attractive
john's second belief was that over the
long term actively managed funds would
lose to the market and over time we've
seen that this is indeed the case with
most funds
but in the late 1970s john's low fees
and long-term outlook weren't very
convincing
at the end of the first year the index
fund had only grown to 17 million
dollars
but eventually when the bull market
started in 1982 after the inflation
crisis of the 1970s the indices finally
started to grow at a substantial rate
this significantly boosted the interest
in index fund investing but index funds
were still largely avoided something
that did help vanguard though was the
start of the 401k era in the 1980s
instead of directly targeting investors
and brokerages with their index funds
vanguard switched its focus to companies
unlike investors and wall street who
were concerned about beating the market
and generating the greatest returns
possible companies were more concerned
about giving their employees a low-cost
reliable and stable investment option
and index funds were perfect for this
vanguard became a top choice for
employee retirement funds and 401k plans
which allowed vanguard to finally gain
some traction
vanguard didn't stop targeting direct
investors either though they actually
came out with more options for direct
investors
in december of 1986 vanguard launched
their second fund which was a total bond
fund in december of 1987 vanguard
launched their extended market index
fund which tracks the entire stock
market since then vanguard has
continuously launched fund after funding
each with a different focus such as
small market cap companies and
commodities all of these new funds
combined with the rise of retirement
funds led to vanguard blowing up during
the 1980s and they ended the decade with
55.8 billion in assets under management
for most funds this would be a fantastic
amount but given vanguard's extremely
low fee structure they needed much more
to make the same amount of money as a
regular 55.8 billion dollar fund with a
0.03 fee for instance vanguard would
only be pulling in 16.7 million dollars
per year despite managing 55.8 billion
fortunately though vanguard's assets
would continue to grow exponentially
throughout the 1990s
the key development in the 1990s and
early 2000s was the rise of tech
companies and the dot-com bubble tech
companies paid their employees extremely
well which made managing their
retirement funds extremely lucrative by
2005 vanguard's assets under management
grew to just under one trillion dollars
in the meantime john retired from
vanguard in 1999 as he reached a
mandatory retirement age at the company
of 70. since john's retirement the new
leaders of vanguard have placed more
focus on actively managed funds but
ironically this is when the popularity
of index funds went through the roof in
the late 2000s warren buffett made his
famous bet against hedge funds and
retail investors have been more than
happy to take it easy and simply enjoy
market returns this newfound retail
interest has skyrocketed vanguard's
total assets under management to a
whopping 7.5 trillion dollars but what i
think is even more impressive than their
crazy balance sheet is their ethics
wall street often gets a bad rep for
terrible ethics and most of the
criticism they get is well deserved but
the same cannot be said about vanguard
the only profit vanguard makes is the
measly fees they charge on their funds
now of course they manage trillions so
they make plenty of money
but what i'm referring to is the fact
that vanguard doesn't actually have any
investors
jon strongly believed that it was a
major conflict of interest to offer
stock in a company that was meant to
generate the best returns possible for
their fund investors
every dollar the company makes is one
less dollar that could have been paid
out to the fund investors
so john decided that vanguard would have
no ownership whatsoever vancar does not
have any stock and it's not privately
owned
instead vanguard likes to say that the
company is owned by all the investors of
their funds
to put in perspective how much vanguard
is giving up with this decision let's
take a look at blackrock blackrock is
the largest asset manager in the world
and they manage over nine trillion
dollars worth of assets blackrock does
have stock and their market cap is 138
billion dollars
even if we say that vanguard was only
valued half as much as blackrock that
would be about 70 billion dollars
john could have easily held on to at
least 25 of the company which would have
given him a net worth of 17.5 billion
dollars
but instead john died with a net worth
of only 80 million dollars
obviously that's not a bad amount
but for someone who literally created
trillions of dollars of value for
american investors that's an awfully
modest salary
something else i want to note is that
john gave half of his salary to charity
truly an insanely inspiring story but
we'll have to see how long vanguard
upholds jon's ethics because jon
unfortunately passed away two years ago
in 2019
i'm sure his legacy with vanguard
however will live on forever
what do you guys think about vanguard's
business model comment that down below
also drop like if john's ethics inspire
you and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]